yemenis in the southern city of taiers
move with purpose
not pausing for fear they are on one of
the front lines in the country's
six-year war
or for fear of a global pandemic they
march on
well-versed and surviving alone
that is bad news for these nurses at
althara hospital
there are no cues for the vaccine
despite a spike in infections last month
a malnourished population and a hobbled
health system
is yemen's third largest city and has
four ventilators
i was surprised when i came to the
medical center and found a low turnout
i got vaccinated along with my whole
family and we're entirely convinced
because the pandemic is widespread and
symptoms are more intense
yemen was given 360 000 doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine five weeks ago
through the global covax vaccine sharing
scheme
seventy thousand were delivered
we started on april 21st but the turnout
has been very low
one reason is a religious belief that
many people have
that taking a shot in ramadan breaks
your fast
it's wrong but that has led many people
not to come
that includes many health workers
in yemen's streets
there is still a lot of uncertainty
about the vaccine maybe it will succeed
or maybe it will fail
i got infected by coronavirus i took
natural herbs and spices
that's what our ancestors used i
recovered
one of us dies only when his time has
come those rare diseases only affect the
rich
and we're not among them vaccine
fears are spreading on social media with
people more scared of the vaccine
than the virus
society needs more awareness and more
education that this vaccine is not as
dangerous and does not
cause blood clots as it's being
circulated
yemen a country of nearly 30 million
people
will receive 1.9 million doses through
the kovac scheme this year
but at this rate maybe that will be a
surplus
charlotte ballas al jazeera